joining us now is someone who knows an
awful lot about our Southern border
that's former Texas governor former
Energy Secretary Rick Perry Governor
good to see you um I really feel for the
people of Texas the only thing that I
take heart in is that the border patrol
Federal border patrol they were saying
they're not going in they're not cutting
that razor wire they're not going to
have a confrontation with Texas National
Guard what if what if Joe Biden then
tries to federalize Texas's guard what's
going to happen yeah good good on those
men and women uh let me say first you
know God bless Greg a uh standing up and
basically saying uh he's not going to
allow uh this continual dilution of our
country this just overrunning of our
border the literal letting in of these
individuals who you nailed it right on
the head uh Sean when you talked about
there's a lot of bad people involved uh
in this that are coming across the
border uh people we don't know who they
are but I guarantee as sure as God made
strawberries that some of them are being
sent here with bad intent in their mind
and and on they're going to they're
going to go do some bad things in this
country and and Greg Abbott and those 25
other Governors that stood up you know
God bless them as well uh I'm telling
you the this Administration likes to
talk about you know constitutional
crisis that' be uh created by Donald
Trump and right here right before our
eyes we see a constitutional crisis
being created by the Biden
Administration and Texans aren't going
to put up with it they're standing up
they're doing what's right and uh you
know I I hope that it doesn't turn into
anything um worse than just you know
being put out but the other thing that's
going to happen is Texas is going to
become a substantially redder State than
it already is those Hispanic
historically Democrats along the border
are seeing what this administration's
doing and they're going to walk away
from the Democrat Party and say no more
we've had it with you we're going to go
join the party that's of a rule of law
and that believes in in keeping our
country safe and sound and economically
viable Governor the two of us spent a
lot of time in this very area we even
did a show from the border right by the
Rio Grand uh was out with you on boats
you got to really educate me in this
particular area um there's nothing in
that decision by the Supreme Court that
forces Texas to take down any wire
there's nothing in that decision that
prevents them from putting up more wire
uh as a matter of fact if I look at the
Constitution I'll look down if you don't
mind uh article four says the federal
government shall protect the states
against Invasion well John Solomon had a
story about all these top FBI luminaries
I mean guys that oversaw the bureau's
intelligence counterterrorism criminal
training Ops uh they're the ones that
said in modern history the US has never
suffered an invasion of the Homeland uh
and yet one is happening now and they
went as far as to say that Joe's Biden's
policies have Unleashed an invasion of
military AG male foreigners who posed
one of the most pernicious ever threats
to American Security Now excuse me
Governor but if that's not a clear and
present d to every American Safety and
Security I don't know what is spot on
Sean let me tell you I don't think
there's anything that needs to get more
coverage right now than that letter by
those individuals who spent a lifetime
protecting America uh and for them to
come forward and say never before have
we seen this type of activity never
before have we seen evidence of people
who have uh harm on their minds to to do
to Americans freely coming into this
country and and the shocking part about
this Sean is that you have a president
of the United States and administration
that seems to be helping them right
along we want to go cut the barter wire
and let these people freely come in and
dilute this country um I'm I'm stunned
that Americans are not just up in arms
literally uh with what's going on and
you know sending a clear message this
Administration is look if if this is how
you plan on getting reelected good luck
my friend because it's not going to
happen I I honestly I feel for law
enforcement because I have so much
respect for them but they have respect
for each other and the fact that border
patrols come out so strongly and so
supportive of the efforts of Governor
Abbott and the guard and and knowing
darn well that Joe Biden created this
crisis um I think has been pretty
inspiring those govern Governors that
you mentioned every Republican Governor
has spoken out in defense of Texas and I
stand with Texas too you once gave me
the honor I'm an honorary Texan Governor
uh I have that document proudly
displayed in my studio and um I really
stand with the people of Texas tonight
this has got to stop it's bad for the
country it always has been and it's of
Joe Biden's making it's horrible
Governor good to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else